[Music]
climate change today is something that
everyone should be concerned by we've
seen changes within not just our own
lifetimes but within the last 10 years
we'll see levels back in the 1990s were
rising rate of about one point seven
millimeters per year but in recent
decades that rate has accelerated and
sea levels now rise on average by three
point two millimeters per year about
eighty percent of the world's population
live around coastlines all over the
world so when ice melts and sea level
rise it has
biodiversity in insect species is
decreasing and so this is lots of animal
life on planet earth that we maybe don't
see with our eyes
lives when you know that there are
things and changes that are already
taking face that it may be too late to
stop so I think we can all take measures
now to try and preserve the Earth's
environment and to reduce the effects of
climate change today making sure that
the imaging of do users clean is a step
that we can really easily take
seeing the beauty of the natural world
it just proves to us that this is
something that's so valuable but if we
were to lose it whoever Bret it's
Google's to prime humans live on air and
so it's worth fighting to preserve
[Music]